ever feel like you were in a flow rut
wish more people noticed you when you
got out to spin or just curious of what
the hidden rules of how to make flow
look good happen to be well friend I've
got you covered cuz in this video I'm
going to break down for you five of my
favorite tips for improving your flow
with LED
POI Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and today I'm breaking down how to
improve your LED flow in a variety of
different spaces but before we dive in
let me give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys pyara
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- buus
friend of the channel Becca be thank you
so very much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission everybody's flow
is unique it is about their relationship
to the prop and how they choose to
express that with their own movement and
their relationship to the music that
they're listening to but that doesn't
mean that there aren't some best
practices when it comes to flowing with
your LED POI in more than a decade and a
half I've seen a lot of flow and I've
done a lot of flow and these to my mind
are the most important tips for getting
the most out of your flow and getting
noticed when you're doing it real quick
if you love Po and flow Arts and you'd
like to see more videos about them
please make sure to subscribe to the
channel so you see every upload as soon
as I make it so let's dive in tip number
one learn from what's worked before po
gets this inspiration from a lot of
different prop disciplines but one of
the biggest is certainly glow sticking
which was the primary Way by which
people spun lit up props before LED po
became widespread and available and
because of this we have a wealth of
tricks from the glow stringing world
that we can look to for inspiration
tricks that have been tried and true for
multiple decades now and that still look
amazing to this day in particular wraps
and tracers look incredible and can be
performed inside of a very small space
plus which they highlight the body of
the performer in a way that few other
LED tricks do and it's no coincidence
that a lot of popular contemporary po
moves are derived directly from tricks
that glow stringers invented decades ago
in particular orbitals and spiral wraps
are among my favorites so when looking
for options of things to add to your own
flow don't be afraid to look into what
has worked before and can definitely
work again in the future but good LED
POI flow does not begin or end with glow
stringing and there are some tricks that
were developed specifically for POI that
I think are a perfect fit for
LEDs tip number two Trails make patterns
pop perhaps more than any other medium
LED poy are perfectly suited for the
type of patterns that were popular
during the height of the tech po
movement flowers hybrids and caps were
all developed with an eye towards seeing
the complete pattern that the PO would
Trace over in the course of the trick
this is an ideal type of pattern to to
use in a dark room where the LED po are
taking advantage of Persistence of
vision to make those patterns pop the
caveat here of course is because those
patterns are so visible with LED POI you
really want to make sure that you're
using as clean a technique as possible
because if you're off even a little bit
well it'll read loud and clear to your
audience to go deep into this world it's
not a bad idea to start with the Vulcan
Tech gospel and all the different
flowers and hybrids that it outlines and
then maybe go a little bit deeper into
things like poly Rhythm hybrids unit
circle hybrids and their close ilk
either way you'll find a lot to love
here so I've talked a bit now about the
kinds of tricks that are a good fit for
Led poy flow but we do also need to talk
about how you make transitions with them
as well tip number three use
contrasts so the fact that led Poise
such a good fit for pattern-based
spinning is also kind of a double-edged
sword because on one side of things it
makes those patterns look clear as day
and on the other it means that if those
patterns aren't different enough it may
not register with the audience that
switch tricks at all if you've got two
tricks that have a lot in common say a
similar hand position or the PO are
spinning in the same timing and
Direction it might be a good idea to
have another trick to pad out between
the two that's markedly different say a
different timing and direction or in a
different plane entirely by varying
things up and making sure that the pyric
don't look too similar you'll also be
sure to give your audience a more
Dynamic show and that's going to keep
them more engaged for longer and it
should be said that if you want to
create an impression that more Vibes
rather than feels very Dynamic you can
make the opposite Choice perhaps string
together a bunch of tricks that have a
lot in common the one downside to this
is that your audience is going to get
bored eventually so make sure that you
do break this up on occasion Okay so
we've talked a lot about what tricks and
transitions to use now I want to talk
just a little bit about what tricks you
might not want to
use tip number four keep it off the
body without a doubt the biggest
limitation of LED POI as a medium is
that usually you can't see the body of
the performer terribly well po tricks
that are B around seeing the
relationship between the PO and the
performer's body tend not to work that
well in these environments in particular
things like body tracers plane braks and
the like tend not to read as well to the
audience or just look like gibberish the
exception of this of course are those
tricks that are based in glow stringing
things like wraps and tracers like we
talked about earlier and specifically
they work because the light from the LED
POI is being used to illuminate the body
of the performer but that doesn't work
with most patterns in many cases the poy
are moving too far away or moving too
fast to affect ly light the body of the
performer make smart choices with the
knowledge that the audience can't see
your body most of the time and it'll
help you come up with more effective
flow all right so for my final tip we're
going to talk about something that is
more fundamental than transitions tricks
and even the history of the prop tip
number five form factor awareness one of
the most important considerations for
anything you do with your LED POI is
going to be the form factor that they
come in because depending upon that form
factor there are going to be some tricks
that work and some that really don't in
particular po that have a form factor
where there's a single point of light at
the very end of the prop tend to be
really effective for things like stalls
floats and point isolations things that
benefit from having one point of focus
at any given time by the same token Rod
shaped form factors that have more LEDs
will do a great job of Illuminating
Trails but they won't look as good with
stalls here you want to make sure that
you're using transitions that center
around pendulums I tend to find that the
more intricate the pattern the less good
a fit it is for that form factor that
looks like a Rod the reason being that
it's just filling up so much space that
when you have a complicated pattern it
just turns out to be gibberish that said
when it comes to simpler patterns like
Caps or basic flowers there is no set of
LED poy that will make them look better
than one of those Long Rod shaped ones
these are truly some of the most
beautiful patterns you can create and
create some amazing photography and
videos so there you go those were my
five tips for how you can improve your
flow with your LED po what are some of
your favorite tips leave me a comment
and let me know
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
y'all Rock and if you out there watching
are not currently supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to patreon at